so you're gonna ask me questions or what
SpaceX will launch into space the most
powerful rocket the world has ever seen
virtual reality headsets will launch in
great abundance and will quickly be
relegated to the world of video games
I think Volkswagens gonna ditch its
diesels and go for electric engines
Apple will not come out with a car in
2016 2016 will be either the first or
second hottest year on record 2016 will
be longer than 2015 because it's a leap
year
yoga pants are going to take over the
world
keep yoga pant has not been moved yet
men will be wearing pink men will be
made fun of for wearing shorts in office
in the summer when it's 100 degrees
though my prediction is that people will
stop making predictions because they'll
realize they don't usually actually come
true how am I gonna predict 2016 I can't
even predict what I'm having for lunch
today
it's a terrible question totally
pointless fool's game but my prediction
is right hell may freeze over fat ladies
may burst into song all the way around
the world but the euro crisis will not
definitely be raising rates the Fed will
raise rates I don't think that the Fed
will raise interest rates substantially
in 2016
Starbucks will introduce a new twist on
their pumpkin spice latte that will
drown out all talk about rates or
inflation Donald Trump will not be like
the president Trump will leave I don't
think Donald Trump definitely will not
Trump will actually admit that it is a
toupee Al Gore will not be elected
president I think I think Hillary
Clinton will be elected credible one the
thing is that we keep predicting that
Hillary Clinton will be president and
then she keeps not becoming Pres
but I'm not gonna go so far out as to
say that Hillary Clinton will not be
President because only a pool at this
point would say that Hillary Clinton is
not going to be President so I'm a
generally pessimistic person
I'm guessing 2016 it's gonna look a
little bit better than 2015 I feel very
optimistic about next year how can you
not be optimistic right
Oh deeply pessimistic I'd say neutral
I'd like to think that it's going to be
a good year
Radiohead's gonna put out a new album
and it's gonna be terrific I'm sure
they'll just work out just fine
should have done this research before
this is going to tell us so much ah the
year of the monkey that's going to be a
little volatile but it's friendly yes